[Applause]
[Music]
i'm cindy i'm the nail salon owner and
very happy to come today for the show
and hopefully i picked one make friend
happy
that's binoy shout out cass to be shout
out to y'all yes
oh my son is very good nita's
photography
photography
you don't look at me like that [ __ ] you
man yo she got that attack on titan
smile man it's just one
mom what are you gonna be looking for
today in the girls fine first and very
nice and been positive
in life beautiful from in and out
i think i trust her yeah
i would you trust your mom to pick a
date i'm just my mom told me i'm no
no
no no no no no no
and i'm speaking from a place of like
arranged marriages
no i would not trust my mom oh [ __ ] mom
you're watching i wouldn't trust you
i'll say it to your face i'll say it
online my mom i'm not trusting you your
mama's watching yeah she's gonna see 20
people say where's ethiopia that's what
she's going to do
where's the open woman that's what we
gonna do your mom's watching
i hope not
i told her to unsubscribe yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but i know her knows here she
probably just go offline try to click
yeah of course what is about doing oh
[ __ ]
ah
try to pick i wouldn't trust my mom to
pick up mom don't question where the
money comes from
is it drugs yes
yes all the drugs selling everything
nobody's gonna know just just take the
money i'd rather she's like i'm doing
crime then she's watching this content
bro shout out to moms my mom definitely
watching you know that my mom watching
yeah your
mom's [ __ ] mama
you know my mom watching show my
instagram once in a while you know why
i'd be shocked watches oh your dad
my dad knows
there you go shout outs to dance
that yes man no
but i don't want to be mean
i think she was calculating her head
yeah she was like
without pause i
respect damn they'd be on the same page
yeah
mom and stuff got the same same taste
good luck
[Music]
you know if andrew tate and his mom
played this [ __ ] they black all 20 of
you guys
were all going on the team
[Laughter]
they're like you have to pick one he's
like he's a high value man there's
different rules i have a masculine duty
to [ __ ] all of you
[Music]
all right ready so let's do like this
okay
mom left her right
you know what she's thinking when she's
looking at this [ __ ]
don't ever stephanie
that's what she's thinking probably yeah
don't be ratchet don't don't be weird
don't be doing no nasty nasty
[Music]
can we touch sure all right so cute
[Music]
if mom is as immigrant as i think she's
gonna say no because my mom would say no
my mom was saying
my heart's pounding awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes ma'am yes man that's that's the way
you should do it i understand i don't
think i don't agree but i get it i get
it i get it i get it
[Music]
so i was wondering if i could actually
titanic you just got her arms back a
little bit
[Music]
no
no
you try to be funny it's not funny
i like being little spoon i'm with the
[ __ ]
[Music]
nice
i'm like short so would you be down to
do a piggy back sure
did you try to hump my my my son
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you have to say with a smile
did you try to help my son that's more
immigranty [ __ ] yes yes that's very
good that's it right there
[Music]
no
she really did that
what did i tell you about embarrassing
the family
i didn't think she would say no
don't do anything you called it don't
know don't do anything don't do anything
too don't don't do anything always hoes
don't do it the family don't do it
if you're going to embarrass our family
don't do it just don't
just be gone
don't exist but don't embarrass the
family
just go to the jungle fight a lion never
return
but don't do it
you doing too much
get rid of her please please
[Music]
yes mom i'll take back what i said i was
disrespectful i said you got that attack
on titan face you do but you don't
deserve that
yo mom was not having this she said get
out of here
who knows
so i kind of figured we would just skip
ahead a little bit could you get down
with me
no
this this
the [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] out on behalf of all my asian
people the [ __ ] out get rid of this
becky get the [ __ ] out
[Music]
yes
mom
no
you were doing so good up until now she
really wants her son to be married
though
um
but
we we do not approve
we don't we we don't do this hi
i'm charlotte nice to meet you
my name is kirsten i'm super nervous
she's she's friendly it's okay how are
you doing i'm good thank you
[Laughter]
dude that's so funny dude yo you you
smoke a doobie before you got there my
girl
i go to cal state fullerton i'm studying
mechanical engineering with an art minor
what happened
my voice different
that was different
no comments hey listen if it's dark and
i hear that voice i'm like hey [ __ ] we
fight
i'm tired i'll just keep it aside we
fight to the death if i just you hey my
name is cal and i'm working from caltech
i'm like [ __ ] you wanna square up [ __ ]
[Music]
i made these shoes these are custom
shoes wow um it's like my frat because
i'm an engineering fraternity yeah i'm a
creative person so i love painting art
drawing playing guitar
so you don't have job
why did you do russian
so you don't have a job that's russian
listen listen i don't know asian accents
that's live right here oh yeah yeah
you don't have dub
is that more filipino you don't have job
you know no job where's your hometown oh
my hometown san jose i don't know are
you vietnamese yeah yes oh vietnamese
you don't have job say
all my vietnamese people tell them he's
wrong
i
oh
yeah
yeah
relatives living
oh yeah it's really nice it's similar to
the football talk
mom
yo play that's your back what the [ __ ]
ben wrap it up shout out to mom for sure
listen tell dog tell the rest of them to
go home yeah they could go home i don't
know if he's into it though it's a wrap
any relationship you have before in the
past i've had two like serious
relationships one actually was with a
woman
[Music]
the way we look at like this is because
we know
immigrant moms or not yeah they'll start
yeah
she's gay
she knows
and my parents are just different but
yeah what they do they don't give a [ __ ]
oh god
my parents you know my parents i mean
listen my mom's muslim
yeah they're not about but they're not
with that yeah so my parents
protestants
i broke up with her a little while ago
we were just both not
mentally stable to be taking care of
each other relationships so we're both
better now
what did i tell you guys what i tell you
isn't that what i [ __ ] described when
i say they're to smile in your face like
get rid of her
she must go that's you [ __ ]
oh my gosh
they don't hear they don't
that's how it'll be
are you uncomfortable no no no
no very nice you tell me about that
honest to tell you yeah
yeah i like that thank you thank you
yeah i like to be
all honest are you ready to date
who
oh my god this feels like such a [ __ ]
throwback to like those old movies
get my girl that's dude where's my car
yes
say it
what dude where's my car
no it says dude what does it say on my
back where's my car no dude
it says dude on yours but where's my car
i don't know it says
and then none then anyways throwback
this is a throwback
are you ready to date whoo
i'm not not okay in general in general
yeah that was like that sounded crazy
not like that um
i mean yeah if someone is
not
he was oh my god
did you pop exam before you got here my
girl
yo
yo hey brian i feel for you brother i
feel for you
if someone worthy
enters the scenario which they haven't
but we'll see
yo
now this is the definition of showing up
to a job interview and coming in
sneakers and jeans hey are you here for
the job i guess if y'all want me
it's just jesus [ __ ] can you try [ __ ]
i'm just here as i don't get fined yo ho
say you're all so beautiful i swear
how did you she's going to say let's
keep
because this is the kind of pr as
immigrants like you don't want to draw
negative attention to yourself and you
don't want to stand out or like get by
press so you do a lot and they do this
with even in the culture not just around
white folks or other people like they'll
just like everyone's so gorgeous
and then as soon as the [ __ ] doors
are closed like way to talk about y'all
[ __ ] she came to here with
those shoes like those are everything
yeah how did you choose the girls yet
the ones
how is it
good
i'm curious i picked this one because he
was admired you know creative thing
artists yeah
[Music]
what's your name
tabiola okay what are you surprised i
had like no idea you know who you picked
i think he picked uh the austrian white
girl yeah who do you think yeah
yeah
great pick yeah for sure
do you like it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god
that's awkward that's awkward i'm sorry
my son i can tell you don't like her she
just said it whoa
[Music]
she said fashion and business and i saw
my mom like lit up but she's great she
seems really cool
probably not but i'm open to anything
she's super creative i'm super creative
too love to chat see where it goes so
he said you like to shop
yeah
yeah you know what's interesting i just
never know i guess well i mean we know
it's not her we know it's not her yeah
yeah too bad we didn't get to see who he
would have picked that's unfortunate
yeah which do you believe you're
watching add that in as a suggestion you
know let us know who you would have
picked so that we can have both compare
but otherwise great video
it's cool it's cool to see immigrants
because i can i'm so much reminded of my
mom 150
okay
but yeah maybe y'all disagree maybe you
guys think our takes were [ __ ] who knows
let us know what you guys think in the
comments i thought she was filipino
yeah
i thought she was rushing